FUCK!
Nooooooo!!
God! FUCK YOU!
WHAT THE FUCK?!
I don't wanna play this anym-
I FU-
`★~ BANG! ~★`   #*~  CRASH! ~*#
`★~ KER-SMASH! ~★`
FUCK!!!
*Happy kitty music*
Ugh!
FUCK!
FUCK! 2..
FUCK! 3..
FUCK! 4..
FUCK! 5..
FUCK! 6..
FUCK! 7..
FUCK!! 8!  (Ultimate combo!)
GOD DAMN IT! PIECE A SHIT!
*Markisaiyan*
OHHHHHHHH!
I hate it I ha-
I just wanna be 50% done!
I JUST WANNA!
*breath*
BE! *breath*
FIFTY PERCENT DONE!!!
UWAAAAAAAAAAAAA!!
Ah.
OH NOOOOO!
Come on! FUCK YOOOOOU!
AAOOHH!
I swear to Christ!
FUCK! YOU!
AHHHHH FUCK EVERYTHING!
*Breath*
AAAAAAHH FUCK ME!
AAHH!
FUCK LIFE!!
OH FFFF- FEDGE BGUH BGUH!
BEHFH PHHFFF!
AHAHAAAA....! AAAAH! AHH!
AAAAH! AAAAGGGGGGHHAAAAAH--
(!) Markiplier.EXE has stopped working (!)
Oh I've never been so angry in my life.
(True.)
What is with you?!
WHAT IS WITH YOU!!?
GET OUT OF MY WAY!!!
(Monkiplier)
I spilled my drink.
GOD!! DAMN IT!
FUCK'N FINALLY!
MOTHER OF GOD!!!
What the SHIT!
MY!
GOD!
FUUUUUUCCK!
OH FFAHAH HAH!!
I THOUGHT HE JUST JUMP'D!
I THOUGHT I WAS
DOOOOOONE!
God damn it!
AHH!!
FUUUUUCK!!!
YEEEEEEEEHEAAHEAAHEEAAH!!!!
YEAH!!!!
OOOOOOOOOOH.
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHAAHAAH!
MOTHERFUCKER!!
I'm too out my-
miiIIIIIIIIIII
IIIIIIIIIIIIIII
IIIIIINNND!!
MOTHER OF...!
._.
Pearl.
MY FINGERS!
THEY DON'T WORK!
THEY DON'T FREAKIN WORK!!
God it's four buttons!
Ohhhhhhh! Why?!
WHY DO YOU GO
IN THE FUCKING
WRONG DIRECTION?!?!??!?!
*Water Spills*
Ugh...
phfff.
NOOOOOOOOO!!
OH GOD!
THAT WAS IT!
AHHH-!
UGGHH!
NO!
WHAT THE FUCK!?
NO! GOD DAMN IT! FUCK!
Oh!
I hit the wrong button!
FUCK!!!
OHHH!!
FUUuuUUUuuUCK!!!!!
ARGH!
C'MOOOOON!!!!
Ffffuck!!
I can't do it!
I CAN'T
FFFFFFUCKING
DO IT!
OK?
*Breath*
FFFFFFUCKING
CRIMINY
JESUS CHRIST!!
OH!
FUCK!
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
FOR 2&1/2 HOURS!!!
OOOOOOOOOOOAHHHH!!
NERRRR!
NAAAEERRR-!!
NEEER!
Ah! Yeah!
Yes! :D
NOOOOOOOOO! D:
NOO-!
NO PLEASE! PLEASE! PLEASE! PLEASE! PLEASE! PLEASE! PLEASE! PLEASE! PLEASE!
NO!
NO! NO! NO! NO! NO!
(Sigh of relief)
Nooo!
NOOOO!!
NOAAAHH!!!
GAH HAAH!!
*Breath*
AAGHHH!  AAGHHH!!
I FUCK-
FUCKING-!
I'M FUCKING-- (Are u ok?)
FUCK EVERYTHING!
EVERYTHING
CAN GO DIE!
I HATE MY LIFE!
I HATE THIS
GAME!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
(sorry for my exaggeration)
UUGGGGGGGGHHHHHH.
(Subtitles by Zi Wang)
(Subscribe to Mark and check out more of his amazing content!)
Just let...
...let me go home!
Let me-
Ahhh!
FINALLY!!